[Música]
la mayoría de las veces cuando le
pregunto a mis alumnos pacientes familia
o amigos cómo estás o cómo te sientes
por lo regular me responden bien o muy
bien y algunas veces me han contestado
porque preguntas es increíble el poco
vocabulario que tenemos para nombrar y
entender nuestras emociones así como la
apertura para hablar de ellas
a las emociones no se les ha dado el
sentido realidad y por ende no se puede
hablar de lo que no existe
estoy segura de que muchas de las
ocasiones que pregunto ellos no se
sienten bien sin embargo es lo que hemos
aprendido a contestar y lo hacemos de
manera automática
en este último año hemos monitoreado en
nuestros síntomas físicos casi a diario
tomamos la temperatura revisamos no
tener dolor de cabeza dificultad para
respirar o para percibir olores y
sabores dolor de garganta así hemos
cuidado nuestra salud tomando distancia
lavando las manos con frecuencia
utilizando gel antibacterial así como
cubrebocas
pero lo mismo deberíamos de hacer con
nuestra salud emocional
mi nombre es mónica durazo y vengo a
hablarles del impacto de nuestras
emociones así como herramientas para
poder escucharlas
entender y hablar de nuestras emociones
y las de los demás nos ayuda a tomar
decisiones ya que nos ayuda a comprender
lo que está pasando allá afuera o en el
mundo interior con nuestros pensamientos
también nos ayuda a mejorar nuestra
salud física nuestras relaciones con los
demás y la creatividad y desempeño del
día a día
he descubierto a través de las personas
cercanas a mí que la salud mental tiene
un peso increíble en nuestras vidas y no
le hemos dado ese valor
platicaba con una amiga que empezó a
tomar terapia para tratar su depresión y
le pregunté cómo se había sentido me
dijo me siento como cuando alguien le
ponen lentes para ver y se dan cuenta
que todo ese tiempo ha sido en las otras
personas
nítido y con colores así me siento yo
con las emociones las emociones nos
hablan escucharlas
seguramente han escuchado la frase toma
las decisiones con la cabeza no con el
corazón
las emociones son una herramienta
valiosísima e incluso a la hora de tomar
decisiones
las emociones en gran medida determinan
nuestro comportamiento aunque tengamos
la misma información tomamos diferentes
decisiones depende si estamos
experimentación es placenteras o
displacenteras
las emociones nos dan información de la
manera en que reaccionamos ante
situaciones que están pasando o
pensamientos que estamos teniendo
cada emoción tiene una función diferente
el miedo nos alerta a un peligro el
estrés pone en marcha en nuestro sistema
de respuesta la culpa actúa como nuestra
moral y la ira nos impulsa a actuar y
solucionar lo que nos hizo enojar
cuando tenemos emociones placenteras
agregamos serotonina dopamina y otros
neurotransmisores que influyen en
nuestro pensamiento
con base en esta información escogemos
el camino que hay que tomar
las emociones que experimentamos
provocan diferentes respuestas
fisiológicas en nuestro cerebro y otros
químicos liberan hormonas y otros
químicos que influyen directamente en
nuestra salud física y emocional
cuando experimentamos emociones
displacenteras nuestro cerebro libera
diferentes hormonas como el cortisol
conocida como la hormona del estrés
cuando la duración y la intensidad del
estrés aumentan se convierte en estrés
crónico y es dañino para la salud
el cortisol a largo plazo inhibe el
funcionamiento de la corteza prefrontal
evitando que procesa la información de
manera eficaz y se ve afectada nuestra
capacidad de concentrarnos y aprender
también puede provocar insomnio aumento
de la presión arterial y pérdida o
aumento de peso
también se ha encontrado que liberar
nuestras emociones puede tener efectos
benéficos en nuestra salud
se ha encontrado que cuando lloramos se
liberan hormonas del estrés y se
producen hormonas como la oxitocina que
tienen un efecto tranquilizante
y tener sentimientos de gratitud
fortalecen su sistema inmune y nos hace
sentir más felices
cuando estamos acompañados de seres
queridos se produce oxitocina conocida
como el amor y está relacionado a
sentimientos de confianza y fidelidad
también reír nos aumenta el flujo de
endorfinas que mejoran nuestro humor y
también reduce la presión arterial
las relaciones humanas son el aspecto
más importante en nuestras vidas gran
parte de lo que sucede en nuestras
relaciones es el resultado de cómo
comunicamos nuestras emociones
comunicamos a los demás lo que queremos
con los mensajes que les enviamos a
través de una comunicación verbal y no
verbal
esto aplica con la familia la pareja los
amigos compañeros de trabajo y de la
escuela
es importante a la hora de comunicar
nuestras emociones ser asertivos y
respetuosos sin agredir al otro y sin
consentir que nos agrega primero es
importante conocer nuestra necesidad no
tomar las cosas personalmente cada
cabeza es un mundo y no suponer que la
otra persona conoce lo que queremos
a la hora de comunicar ser claros y
directos con lo que queremos y con lo
que sentimos
y ser empáticos y comprender la postura
del otro
si me hubieran preguntado hace 10 años
que se imaginaban una plática en una
plataforma con millones de suscriptores
mi respuesta hubiera sido que no
siempre es una alumna tímida me da mucho
miedo hablar en público
tenía pensamientos de miedos que se
burlaron de mí y de equivocarme
fue hasta que empecé a estudiar la
carrera de psicología donde fui entrando
al misterioso mundo de las emociones
me fui conociendo y preparando para
diferentes proyectos donde tenía que
presentar algún trabajo y fui sintiendo
mayor seguridad
y poco a poco esos sentimientos de miedo
y pensamientos de hacer el ridículo se
fueron viendo
a lo largo de mi trabajo con los alumnos
y pacientes me ha dado cuenta de la
importancia de la inteligencia emocional
especialmente porque lo viví como alumna
y ahora lo experimentado como maestra y
psicoterapeuta
piensen en esta situación dos alumnos
inteligentes estudiaron con tiempo para
su examen final de matemáticas uno está
seguro y tranquilo el otro nervioso y
agitado el resultado y la experiencia
del examen puede ser muy diferente el
mundo académico y laboral está cada vez
más competido por lo que la exigencia se
vuelve más alta pero cada día veo a los
estudiantes maestros y profesionistas
más cansados desmotivados y estresados
le damos mucha importancia al desarrollo
académico y profesional pero son igual
de importantes el aspecto emocional
físico y social
está todo conectado
el aprendizaje y enseñanza son procesos
donde experimentamos muchísimas
emociones pero no está bien que
predominen el cansancio la tristeza la
desmotivación y el estrés
un alumno maestro o profesionista
cansado y estresado no va a tener la
misma motivación desempeño y
satisfacción
hace dos años era maestra de tiempo
completo estaba estudiando maestría veía
pacientes por las tardes saliendo del
trabajo y dando clases de spinning yo
sentía que tenía un peso muy grande de
tener que cumplir con todo y abandonar
algo de lo que estaba haciendo era
fracasar y excepcionar a las personas a
mi alrededor
me preguntaban cómo estaba y mi
respuesta siempre era que bien porque
reconocer y expresar que estaba cansada
era signo de que no estaba pudiendo con
todo
un día me senté con mis papás les dije
que ya no quería seguir estudiando
estaba cansada y estresada
me dijeron que me entendían y que la
decisión que tomara me iban a apoyar
después de hablar con ellos sentir un
alivio sentí que no tenía por qué cargar
con todos sola y que podía pedir ayuda
pero lo más importante que era válido
cómo me sentía
las emociones nos hablan escucharlas
un alumno me dijo que él pensaba que la
inteligencia emocional era reprimir las
emociones
las emociones son energía la palabra
viene emoción del griego que significa
movimiento y como bien se sabe la
energía no se crea ni se destruye sólo
se transforma
sí reprimimos las emociones si
reprimimos esa energía tarde o temprano
va a tener que salir
nos enseñan que apagar nuestras
emociones es lo que se ve bien pero las
emociones ahí están no se van esta
energía no puede nada más apagarse se va
a convertir en otra cosa en lágrimas
dolor de cabeza malestar en el estómago
tensión en la espalda y cuello no la
garganta temblor en los brazos o piernas
y ahí es a donde quiero llegar
lo que no reconocemos con palabras el
cuerpo lo comunica lo que intentamos
callar el cuerpo lo expresa
las emociones nos hablan escucharlas
socialmente hay culpa y vergüenza de
expresar emociones ciertas emociones son
aceptadas y otras no tanto y hay
emociones adjudicadas al cierto género y
edad en la que son permitidas también
creo que existe un miedo a conocer
nuestras emociones como si fuéramos a
encontrar algo que no podemos manejar
entonces lo hacemos un lado y le vamos
aventando más cosas encima pero como es
el montecito de ropa sucia arriba de la
silla tarde o temprano lo vamos a tener
que lavar
me gustaría mencionar herramientas de
apertura a las emociones con uno mismo y
con los demás
lo primero con lo que tenemos que
empezar es con reconocer nuestras
emociones cómo se sienten físicamente
darles un espacio entender que las
provocó algo pasó en el exterior o fue
un pensamiento que tuve
ponerles nombre y regularlas no
juzgarlas sino entender de dónde vienen
tener responsabilidad afectiva requiere
conocer nuestras emociones y saber
regular las tomar responsabilidad de
cómo nos sentimos y cómo actuamos así
como cuando una persona es vulnerable
con nosotros acompañarla y escucharla
también es muy válido decir si no
estamos emocionalmente disponibles en
ese momento
en la prepa donde trabajo en monterrey
parte de mi trabajo es darle el
seguimiento académico y emocional a los
alumnos platicado una vez con un alumno
y me dijo money tú siempre me escuchas y
tú también debes pasar por cosas
difíciles si quieres plática me algo y
yo te escucha
a acompañar al otro desde las
experiencias más enriquecedoras que he
tenido
hablar de lo que estamos sintiendo con
un ser querido es de lo más valioso que
hay
que el otro también reconozca lo que
estamos sintiendo y que es válido de
sentir
si una persona cercana a ustedes les
pregunta cómo están o cómo se sienten
intenten responder algo diferente a bien
mal normal casual y amplíen el
vocabulario
durante la pandemia otra estrategia que
utilizamos en clase con los alumnos de
psicología fue llevar un registro
emocional de sus emociones a lo largo de
seis semanas
mínimo una vez al día tenían que
registrarse emociones y colorear la
emoción que había predominado en el día
el formato era libre cada quien escogía
emociones diferentes depende de las que
experimentaban con más frecuencia y las
coloreadas del color que ellos querían
a la mitad de la actividad
comenzaron a registrar más de una
emoción al día
llevar un monitoreo de nuestras
emociones nos permite hacer conciencia
de cómo nos sentimos en el día a día
entender que provocó nuestras emociones
y cómo las estamos sintiendo
y al final pero no menos importante
recomendaría a tomar psicoterapia con un
profesional de la salud yo personalmente
me inclinado más hacia la psicoterapia
psicoanalítica
la terapia es un espacio donde eres
escuchado
reconoces que tus emociones son válidas
de sentir
reflexionas de dónde vienen y también de
los patrones que nos llevan muchas veces
sentirnos de cierta manera
nos permite tomar acción y elegir el
rumbo en la vida que queremos tomar
nos ayuda a sanar y cerrar heridas y
poder contar historias que nunca
habíamos podido platicar con alguien más
de contarla más de una vez y llega ese
día que la podemos contar sin quebrar
nos
los invito a
conocerse y entenderse y vivir la vida
con emociones y como dice la frase
popular cada día ser más humanos menos
perfectos y más felices muchas gracias